in the 15th edition of the computer
chess championships
the new stockfish that's nnue for those
who don't speak updated officially
neural net
had 114 wins 77 draws
and one single loss you're about to see
that loss in this video
and as we dive into it we have to of
course mention the fact that this new
stock fish is all the rage all the
discussion
in the machine learning chess world
environment is it the future of the
sf open source community will all their
focus go there
will there ever be updates past sf11 i'm
going to tell you all the rumors i'm
hearing and what i think
is actually going to happen at the end
of the video so stick around for that
for now
it's time to see how stuffless stuff
all i know is stuffless rendered
stockfish toothless pun intended
in this particular french opening which
is not the only reason i chose it don't
don't worry
obviously i do love when white gets the
dub here against the uh
the inferior french defense but jokes
aside were in a main line that has been
played many times by
strong grandmasters on both sides knight
f3 knight c6 bishop e3 and and this is
exactly what we expect
to see in mainline classical french
theory c takes d4
and then knight takes d4 we reach our
first kind of critical decision point to
understand the goals of how each side is
going to play
stockfish played the move queen to b6
which is the sharpest most pressing
variation if you look up
the opening you'll note that bishop to
c5 has traditionally been
the most popular move of course is
totally fine but queen to b6 points out
the potential dysfunction
in white's uh situation it hits b2 with
no
easy way to defend it you can't move
this knight to anywhere to block the
queen's gaze without the bishop falling
moving the queen hangs the knight so you
see there's there's some issues here
which is why
queen b6 has gained popularity and it
pushes white
to choose the only real way forward
which is to call black's bluff are you
going to take the pawn or not
and black has shown that he is ready to
do so in most main line theory
after rook to b1 queen a3 we pause again
just to point out that
your eye will be drawn if you haven't
seen these lines before to moves like
knight c to b5
it's a move that forks the queen hits c7
and guards the a5 square so there's no
way for the queen to come back and guard
both
but the problem with knight to b5 is
that after queen a2 your rook is
having been been hit you have to move it
and then knight to c7
is a check but not a fork so just a
check now you can play this line and
white and black have both
received victories in this uh very very
sharp and tactical
middle game but it's not necessarily
considered white's most solid approach
for an advantage
apparently stevelas was aware of this
theory and played the move bishop to b5
after knight takes d4 bishop d4 we get
a6
and then bishop takes d7 bishop takes d7
reaches our first kind of instructive
moment whether you
play the french or not i'm going to
describe to you why rook to b3 is the
main line here
and not the move rook to b7 the key
point is that rook to b7 right away runs
into bishop to b4
now the queen and bishop are obviously
developed well putting pressure on the
queen side
but the main thing is that they've
actually cut off the rook from
retreating here to the b3 square
what ends up happening is after the move
castles bishop to c8 to save your bishop
and then black castles there's no real
way for white to untie that the position
is still roughly unclear
but bishop d7 and rook c8 are coming
black doesn't have any other problems
remember white was just winning back the
pawn nothing more
and the fact that the queen and bishop
have been able to maintain their
aggressive post over here
is the annoying thing you really wish
you had taken care of that earlier
that leads us to rook to b3 which is the
most popular move played by all
grandmasters
and stuffless in our video you gain a
tempo on the queen
force her backwards and only then regain
your pawn all theory
now rook to c8 is what was played by
staffish i think it's the best move
we should note that queen h4 shack was
played by ogden stein versus fabio
caruana several years ago
uh even though fabi didn't go on to get
a win the multiple tempos that he gained
on the queen and then this move queen to
d4
led to an advantage for white even with
the draw uh
the second move instead of rook to c8 is
to voluntarily put your queen on d8
right away this is worth mentioning
for bigger reasons one hikara nakamura
was playing the black pieces here
against sergey karjakin
shout out to our boy hikaru but also
because this was the only game
amongst strong grand masters where white
employed the idea we're going to see
from this groundbreaking approach by
supless f5 was played here
it didn't lead to the same success the
main reason is that hikaru recognized
that taking would not be ideal
for what the french structure normally
wants right f5 is designed to kind of
undermine
the solid house that black builds his
empire on right this very very nice
french pawn chain
uh and the reason that it's no it
doesn't actually disrupt that is because
black can play queen to c8 with tempo
and then the move queen to c4 this move
actually stopped white from getting
castled
leads to some problems and ultimately
the position was very equal
so in the game that's not what uh what
happens rook to c8 is played
castles happens and now on queen to d8
we're in a main line that looks very
similar to what we just saw between
karjakin and nakamura
but what's the big difference there is
no queen to c8 coming to c4
to stop y from castling and now after
the move f5
we see the idea employed by karjakin
with a little bit more heat behind it
the rook is already on the f-file which
is going to lead to critical tactics
we're going to show
and we know that in this position if
this is the house you build
all your plans on in the french you
better have good concrete material and
tactical reason
to take and break it it's exactly the
kind of move you would want to see an
engine challenge another engine in
because we know that even with the
neural nets
if they don't see an answer for why
something is bad they're going to take
the material they're offered
in this position after f5 we're going to
get to all the theory that was
before we do i want to say the other
moves tried by strong grand masters for
those who
do play the french or this position for
either side you want to look into it
rook f3 was actually played in this
position by alexander grisha
against shiroff in 2019 so not too long
ago recommend you might want to check it
out the move queen e3 was also played
by shiroff on the other side of the
color against uh esteban forsen
in linares in 2018. so those are the
those are the two most recent games by
top grand masters
but as as we said f5 has not been a move
other than that car y'all can try
that has had any real success but in
this position
steufless plays it and stockfish calls
his bluff says i'm going to take the
pawn
i think that it's worth it i can then
bring my bishop here
i don't need my pawn chain to stay super
solid
in a french like i normally do plus
there's other problems here
i can't really develop my bishop to the
squares i want like like bishop to b4
bishop a3 is useless bishop e7 might
gain some tempos and some attacking
chances because like i said this rook is
here
so it's not just that f5 was played and
let's say stockfish made a bad move that
nakamura didn't
didn't do by taking the pawn it's that
black is already having trouble
not taking the pawn that that is maybe
most illustrated in the light i analyzed
here with the move bishop c5 what if you
what if you don't take the pawn and deny
it
in this position we see a brilliant move
the move knight a4 was planned by
stoopless
now at first sight it hangs the knight
but let's take a look bishop takes a4
is met by f takes e6 f takes e6 and then
sometimes all it takes is just simple
transition
and a grabbing of an open file to point
out to black that there's no real way to
stop checkmate
uh that's exactly the line that again i
analyzed it
myself along with the help of my
chess.com team we don't actually know
what sublist was going to play but that
looks to be
a clearly clearly strong option note
that if 984 is met bishop takes d4y can
take
we end up transitioning into something
closer to looking equality in a rook
ending
but actually the position is already
borderline lost here for black i'll play
out the whole line just to show you that
the seventh rank
leads to pawns that are munched and
ultimately white ends up just up a ton
of material here in a rook ending which
should be enough to win
so that that illustrates the fact that
f5 was played
stockfish broke meaning broke what a
human would want to do
like nakamura keeping the chain together
but there weren't a ton of obvious other
options
so e takes f5 is played and now what's
where's the beef what's the point well
the first thing white does is double
down where he's strong he plays rook
after b1
and i keep saying he and she all the
time with these engines forget it's an
itch but we're not going to refer to it
like that
my my bad and i'm not trying to offend
anyone or any any anybody all right
rook everyone is played here by white it
doubles down on the pressure on the b
file and again makes it hard for black
to find good moves
queen a5 was played but bishop to e6 was
moment we analyzed
now knight to e2 is played bishop to c5
the trade and then queen to b4
illustrates a key point which is that
black can no longer castle the queen
owns the knight owns the day rook takes
c2 doesn't really change it we'll just
put our knight in a dominant square and
go on to have a crushing attack
so the main point is bishop e6 not a
great move i tried to give other
examples
and again this is the philosophical
storyteller in me i want to make sure
when we see
these computers and these engines blow
our minds everyone are they really
teaching us something that we can apply
to our games are they really improving
on strong grand masters so
for those of you that have been critical
say danny get to the beef i'm giving you
the beef i'm giving you the story line
that's leading to why this
mind-blowing middle game is so impactful
because it does improve on the way the
grand masters approached you previously
and there weren't any other real better
options so again here
i've looked at bishop e6 right there was
there was nothing to do that
white's just so much better on a space
level the knight comes around
and it's coming into strong squares
which is uh
why you would want to trade off the
bishop owning the dark squares but then
you can't get castled um the other move
we looked at bishop e7 is a natural move
bishop b6 just wins on the spot very
hard to find any useful moves here
for black queen a5 looks like a very
logical move that isn't bishop e6 or
bishop e7
and this is where the wheels start to
come off and we can all take a breath
and get excited
so the problem for white is white did
all the things i said you sacked the
pawn to ruin the structure
but now queen a5 stops you from moving
the knight actually guards the pawn
where's the beef i'll slowly unwind my
position here
you can't really bring more pieces into
the attack because i actually have
threats on c3 right
well that's where the mind blowing
begins wrong queen to g5 is played
stoofless calls stockfish's bluff and
actually laughs in the face of danger
here with the knight hanging
now taking the knight right away is not
really an option
the main point is that rook takes c3
immediately
just falls down to the fact that white
can play rook takes d7
and after king takes d7 we have the move
queen takes f5 check
followed by rook infiltration but the
point is
after the move queen to g5 is played and
black plays bishop to e6 to solidify
white laughs in the face of danger again
with the move rook 1 to b6
white is bringing everybody over here to
the attack and note that black
now can't develop the bishop on f8
because of more problems than one
queen takes g7 as a threat bishop e7
can't be played here because it's
because it's checkmate but the fact that
we're also threatening to open up the
seventh rank is gonna be more reasons
we're gonna find out
that black can't develop so rook one to
b6
looks good it brings pressure other than
the fact that rook takes c3 is played
what are the moves where their precise
work takes to be let me show you h6 if
you're trying to unwind just to show
examples of clearing the seventh rank
i mentioned it i should just show it you
take on e6 followed by check and takes
and the attack is unstoppable
developing the bishop elsewhere like we
said e7 is a non-starter but bishop a3
and just about anywhere else
runs into queen takes g7 and again rook
takes e6 followed by check and made on
d7
is unstoppable so nothing to do besides
rook takes c3 we all agree
now the move this is it white in this
position
plays the move h3
we've given up material a piece
and how has the attack been improved by
the move h3
absolutely crazy because we analyze this
i analyze this myself and then
and then jeremy helps me out analyzing
it and a guy that works so hard on
chess.com lessons they're amazing
you should check them out and we
literally went through
options and could not find moves for
black so we came up with the best
subscription for it which was the most
amazing sig swing i've ever seen
the point is that we've established a
lot of reasons why the bishop can't
develop
queen takes g7 and then the seventh rank
clears
h6 weakens the light square so rook
takes e6 wins on the spot
um moving the queen to squares that
don't keep an eye on either the rook or
the the backwards attack coming to the
back ranks we're going to see why
in critical variations coming up the
most logical thing to do
if you can't move any of these pieces is
to bring your rook back to safety which
is what stockfish did
having won the piece and here's the move
that might actually be just as good as
h3 in terms of why it puts black and
zugs one rooks to c8 also does open
ideas between e1
and the second move c3 says that doesn't
that that's not
not naga going to work here anymore the
whole point with this
is that white has actually prepared a
loft for the king to hide
and with the move c3 black is
actually in zugzwang here uh
we're going to start to see why so queen
moves we're played in the game we're
going to establish why queen
leaving this square is bad if you if
what if you take the pawn on c3 again
this is critical rook to be a check rook
to c8
is met by queen to c1 the fact that
white actually just
lost both pieces on the c file is why
the attack ends up being winning here if
you play rook takes c3
again check okay the king can't move by
the way because it's checkmate
uh no real no real other options here
rook back to c8 queen to c1 and the game
is over
rook takes v8 the king escapes the queen
comes in we've got all kinds of
checkmate funk coming
so black move the queen queen to a4
again we've established the king side
isn't going anywhere
king to h2 the move removes the king
from any potential checks
and again puts black in a spot where he
has no moves so we move the queen to a3
just waiting in the position
now the move rook to a7 is played and
this is another reason why it moves like
queen a5 were no good because rook a7
was coming anyway it basically
transposes to the game
the point is black has no way to develop
and get the king out of this position
and everything about white's position is
clearly going to be improved
we can win the a pawn and start pushing
it we can continue to have dominant
threats along the sixth and seventh rank
the the other pieces can't leave the
back rank without more pawns falling
everything is falling apart a5 is played
to avoid rook a7 takes a6 now we go back
to b7
and after the move f4 we get rook back
to a7 white is just sitting tight until
black runs out of moves
a4 is played now the move rook b to a6
official
officially threatens to take a6 along
with keeping all the other ideas open
that you still had on the b
file which was to play things like rook
to b8 rook to b8 by the way constantly
threatens ideas if rook takes c6 because
the rook is hanging if i didn't
establish that earlier the only reason
you didn't do that is because you don't
want to leave
the seventh rank for black to get
developed but as you get the pressure
here
white's not going uh white's attack is
not getting any worse and black isn't
going anywhere
here black played f3 the notation i made
for myself is
what else again let's establish moves
here
if the move bishop to e7 is played
white's winning on the spot with queen
takes g7
and again black really hasn't improved
anything things like rook f8 queen takes
h7
you didn't achieve the purpose of
developing the bishop which was to get
the king castled
if the queen goes anywhere that isn't
keeping an eye on this bishop rook takes
e6 wins immediately on the spot
black is again running out of moves the
other movie analyzed but if you play
rook g8 to guard the pawn so that you
can get developed
now queen takes f4 threatens rook takes
e6 and queen to f7
so bishop e7 and then queen to f1 coming
around here
again this key thing with rook g8 or the
other idea of bishop b7
is that neither move actually achieve
your goal of developing the king side
which would be to get the king castled
you're actually losing the right to
castle
uh what about moves like queen to c1
staying aggressive now we have rook a8
threatening rook takes e6 which again
would have been a common theme with rook
to b8 ideas if the queen had wandered
too far
bishop e7 rook takes e6 we'll just give
one line we analyze rook takes c8 and
rook c7
is bob's your uncle here as the queen
and bishop continue to launch the mating
attack
i think one of the last moves i haven't
analyzed besides f3 uh
let's see would be what about queen to
b2 again just like queen to c1 we saw
here
in this case you can play rook takes e6
right away with queen h5
and after g6 because the queen isn't on
c1 you actually have queen g4 gaining a
tempo
and then queen takes f4 because the
queen is not guarding the f pawn
again unstoppable attacks coming to
black along the f-file
so we've established no queen c1 no
queen to b2 no rook g8 bishop e7
is the last one i know we already talked
about that this falls and you haven't
gotten out
so basically nothing to do but f3 and
here comes the final
uh push through with the combo queen h5
threatening rook takes e6
the move g6 is played queen takes f3
renewing the threat of rook takes e6
finally we see bishop e7 now you can do
it because the g
pawn isn't hanging and you've blocked
the seventh rank but now rook takes a4
queen to b2 rook back to a6 renews all
kinds of threats over here against the
king
and stockfish finally cracked when he
played the move queen to b8 as there was
no real way to
to do anything right um getting the king
out you just lose the piece back right
moving the bishop anywhere there's
infiltration with queen takes d5 anyway
so out of moves the queen retreats and
the final
the final climax to the combination is
rook takes e7
king takes queen to f6 shaq king d7
and rook d6 check the mating net is real
king to c7
is met by queen to e7 and made on d7 so
the only option
is to sacrifice the queen right back on
d6 and now we have e takes d6
and white is just crushing and a queen
and dark square dominance attack versus
the king
of course i'm going to show you the rest
of the game because we always do but the
main point
of the h3 ziggs wong the combo that had
black
completely frozen has already been
illustrated the funny thing that i
always get
in these videos on is i want to show you
the end but the truth is this is just a
completely winning position
with a dominant attack ownership of the
dark squares and an outside past a pawn
and i almost don't always enjoy showing
you the final moments because the
computers don't always have the best
technique
uh when those neural nets take over
queen f1 rook c4
a4 note that the pawn cannot be taken
because the queen to b5 check
bishop f5 a5 rook to a8 and now g4
using both sides of the board is exactly
what they should do it is an instructive
thing when the queen is playing against
the rooks
the more you split the board in half and
the queen flexes
the harder it is for the pieces to
coordinate right so just always remember
that tip i've given it many times
bishop backs up queen to b1 again the
queen is flexing by popping to diagonals
taking advantage of multiple weaknesses
not just one
this is how the queen will outplay
pieces time and time again
king takes queen b6 check and after
bishop c6 sorry rook c6 bishop e5
more material falls and the game is over
note again rook takes a5 would have been
met
by queen to c7 check forking so rook ca
queen b5
i'm gonna get a little faster here
because this is just a queen
against a dominant brook and bishop
where it gets even worse here when the
rook has to give itself up
for the new lady on b8 again sometimes
the ending of these are a little bit of
unnecessary checks and confusing
approaches that they take i don't always
get it
but sometimes i love it sometimes i
don't uh
queen takes finally we get see this is
what i'm talking about it's like why
why am i here i just
finish the j-o-b right so anyway it
always ends with something nutty
but in the end they do prove that
despite giving up the queen for free
they know how to checkmate
and they get the job done but ultimately
this position back here in the middle
game as we get to it
not just the combo or let's say the new
approach that was proven super powerful
with f5
but then the follow-up right queen to g5
the presence of mine of how difficult
black's position would be to unwind
despite the material losses
c3 and h3 back to back just absolutely
nasty freeing the king
and putting black and zigzang as a
highlight one of the key points
c3 really only puts them in zugswong
because because you see that if they
take it
that's actually a bad idea because it
opens the c file
and that was one of my favorite parts
about the position the rest of it was a
game of tickle until black finally ran
out of moves and white's combinations
got nasty enough to end the game so uh
it was just it was absolutely nuts if
you're if you're not following
the computer chess championship you
should probably
do that you can head over there just by
going to
chess.com ccc uh there's literally games
going right now it looks like we got
fire and
ethereal thrown down and like i said the
news at the end of the day that i've
heard
is that the stockfish nnue project again
updated officially neural debt
is going to be taking the majority of
the resources partly because the results
have been so accidentally fantastic
uh taking the approach that stockfish
had plugging it in
to the neural net let the machine learn
on its own approach
has seen significant elo gains the kind
of gains they haven't seen in five years
that's enough for you to relocate your
resources right
and it may actually change the game
forever in terms of what the future is
we know there's the pure alpha zeros and
the pure leelas and then what about
these hybrids right
when do we eventually blow ourselves up
with skynet becoming active and who's
going to be our john connor right
probably stockfish will be leading the
way for the machines
but that doesn't mean for you fans of
the more traditional uh brute force
hardware that they're giving up
i actually hear a little birdie has told
me that a stockfish 12 is actually
coming out very
soon my belief is that they're pushing
it out because they already made enough
progress
not to justify not doing it they might
as well at this point but that after
that
the rumors will be true and that
probably most of the sf open source
community
will just be focusing on the neural net
approach uh from this
from this moment forward so anyway leave
a comment let me know if you hear that
i'm wrong and the rumors are different
let me know if you enjoyed the game i
certainly did it was a lot of fun not
just because the french got destroyed
uh and hopefully you appreciate the
breakdown and understand that when they
make breakthroughs like that on the
board
with f5 and this idea of a stream c3 it
is going to impact
uh the most elite chess that is played
by the humans that are still playing our
game
uh thanks for watching again please hit
the subscribe button if you haven't
already and i will see you around
on chess.com